[Music]
and a good afternoon to you thank you so
much for joining us at four o'clock on
this monday i'm kirsten joyce
and i'm denise valdez we've had another
spike in cobit hospitalizations
they rose to their third highest level
yesterday so let's get right to the
numbers here at four o'clock
nevada reporting just shy of 2 000
new patients with confirmed or suspected
cases of coronavirus
our state also saw more than 1900 new
infections
taking that total case number above 205
thousand
and six people died clark county
reporting the majority of those new
cases at about 1500
and one new death as well more than 132
thousand people have recovered though
from copen in clark county
taking our recovery rate to 85.3 percent
state health leaders warn even if it
seems like the numbers are leveling off
the surge is not over just yesterday
nevada set a record for covet patients
in the icu
the i-team's david charns is live in the
newsroom with the warning
as we head into the holidays david
kirsten so the days when hospitals have
had the most coveted patients have all
been this month with yesterday being the
third highest
just yesterday state hospitals reporting
a record 437
people in the icu for covet 19 a record
we're also nearing a high for
hospitalizations hospitals reporting
nearly 2
000 coveted patients today as denise
mentioned the high
is just a little bit higher than that
and right now statewide icu's are
three quarters full state leaders
telling us today hospitals are ready for
an influx of cases
as people gather over the holidays and
tourists come in to celebrate
but they did not get into any specifics
when i asked about this today
they did say hospital capacity has
always been something to watch
the governor has extended the pause that
we're in right now
not not entirely but in large part
because of demand and strain
on our hospitals in the state of nevada
caleb cage there the state's kova 19
response director also reminding us to
limit groups to people you live with
that limit is capped at
10 people right now he also says the
slight decrease we're seeing in cases
cases not hospitalizations shows that
that stay at home 2.0
is working but he cautions we expect to
see another surge
after the new year live in the newsroom
i'm david charns 8 news now